- So wait, before you got the show Scandal
you did a lot of private,
was it catering gigs?
- Oh yeah. I had every job,
but yes, I catered a lot.
I catered, you know, Hugh
Jackman's super bowl party
or every Sunday night dinner
at Courtney Cox's house
with Jennifer Aniston and
all these fancy people.
It was so yes, it was.
- Was it intimidating? or was it like,
were they all really cool?
- It was at first?
Everybody was actually cool.
And you know what? It was
such a Hollywood story.
I used to come up with people
like, are you making it yet?
Like, did you book a job?
Like, no, but I cleaned
her dishes. Whatever.
(laughing)
It's fine.
- But you know, what's really weird.
- I love it!
You know, when you meet
people would always ask me
which celebrities have you met? What men?
And I'd say like, oh yeah,
I've seen Justin Timberlake.
I've seen Brad Pitt.
I've seen all these guys
and really they didn't do it for me.
Except one guy, I was hosting.
- Please say it was me! Was it me?
(laughing)
- It wasn't! Because I
didn't know you had sight.
I didn't know you could
sing. I know it's crazy
I'm at my host stand, motorcycle pulls up,
helmet comes off it's a slow-mo hair
situation, my knees start shaking
I'm having a real reaction
to like a celebrity.
Like I like how I feel about you.
(laughing)
And then, and, and he
slowly walks up and he is
like a male triangle,
like perfectly shaped.
And it's Keanu Reeves.
- [Jenny] Oh yeah, oh yeah
- [Kelly] We've had him on, he's so nice!
- [Katie] Well, what I've heard
is that he's the night off!
- He's also like the nicest human ever,
he's so kind, yeah.
- I would like to pat
myself on the back, that
I really I have a good
radar for a good guy
his soul, his soul, his spirit
- That's good. He is so kind.
I love, I love the whole set up though.
Arriving on a motorcycle, hair in the wind
- [Katie] He was the hottest
- Hear, the catering at
this party was amazing.
(laughing)
Who made this awesome food?
- [Kelly] I love that everyone always..
- To be fair he didn't really be..
- [Kelly] goes to Bill and Ted
- He was just like, you know Reeves
the reservation I'm like
uh huh let me just like
take you to your table.
You can follow me this way.
(laughing)
- Did y'all ever have a situation
like before you had made
it with a celebrity?
Did you ever have anything an encounter?
- Yeah.
- You know, I had a fi speaking of Aniston
when we were doing the
horrible boss's movies
she invited me to a, a party at her house.
And my wife was like, well
you should bring like a
bottle of wine and be polite.
But I'm like, this is like
this was like a written invitation.
I'm like this, I think
this is a big party.
I think they're gonna have catering. Um
And I was like, I don't know
if we should bring a bottle of wine.
And so Mary Lewis says, I'm
bringing a bottle of wine.
She brings it in. We walk in the door.
The first person I see
is Tom cruise, Ellen, Jen
And I was just like, gonna put the bottle
back in the purse into, you know.
(laughing)
Throw it into the bushes
- It was probably like
an okay bottle of wine.
I mean, it was like nice, but not nice.
- It was like, like a $8 bottle of wine.
(laughing)
- This is just for you, Jen.
- We got this at Ralphs.